frente a la costa del condado taiwanés
de pingtung el ejército taiwanés realiza
ejercicios militares lanzando artillería
con fuego real estos soldados están
simulando como defenderían la isla si
alguna vez fuera atacada estos
simulacros se producen mientras el
ejército chino realiza ejercicios
alrededor de taiwán desde el jueves el
entrenamiento es una respuesta a la
visita a la isla de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de eeuu nancy
pelosi una medida denunciada por beijing
mientras que taipei dice que los
recientes simulacros son ensayos para un
ataque chino
23 mientras ine ha utilizado los
simulacros en su libro de jugadas
militares para preparar la invasión a
taiwán está llevando a cabo ejercicios
militares a gran escala y lanzamiento de
misiles así como si hubiera ataques
campañas de desinformación y coerción
económica en un intento de debilitar la
moral pública en taiwán
china considera como propia a la isla
autogobernada y espera reunificar taiwán
con el resto de su territorio si es
necesario por la fuerza ante los
comentarios del ministro de asuntos
exteriores de la isla beijing se
mantiene firme este supuesto ministro de
asuntos exteriores no es más que un
director de una de las oficinas
regionales de asuntos exteriores de
china las contramedidas de china están
totalmente justificadas son una
advertencia a los provocadores y
castigan a las fuerzas independentistas
de taiwán junto con los simulacros china
ha golpeado a eeuu con sanciones también
ha suspendido las próximas
conversaciones en materia de clima y
defensa con washington